don't do this she's not sure what she
wants let me give you a clue
team edward or team jacob but that's a
question you haven't heard in a while
we all had our fair share of vampire
crushes back in middle school but
looking back
you've gotta admit that a lot of
twilight's most romantic moments
were super cringy whether it's edward's
intense sniffing or jacob acting like a
lovesick puppy
there were a lot of red flags that bella
just didn't care about
from the cullen's weird relationships to
how everyone was way too involved in
edward and bella's love life
here are the best of the absolute worst
moments from the twilight saga
the twilight awkwardness starts pretty
much right out of the gate
bella getting too close has edward
quickly running away because she just
smells
way too good it sure doesn't look like
that in this scene though and we're sure
bella was wondering whether or not she
accidentally skipped the deodorant that
morning
but it is a pretty good starter for
their relationship because when it comes
down to it
the whole series is about how hard it is
to resist bella's tantalizing scent
kind of keep to themselves yeah cause
they're all together
as a teenager it seemed really romantic
and very adult to be able to live with
your significant other
but jess was right when she said that
all of the cullens being involved in
romantic relationships with each other
is pretty disturbing
come on no parent would really let this
happen right
that should have been the first clue
that all these kissing cullens weren't
really teenagers i'm designed to kill
when edward finally reveals his true
self to bella it's just a whole roller
coaster of weirdness
first she's enticed by his diamond skin
and then he points out all the reasons
he would make a terrible boyfriend
and probably eat her for a snack before
their first date
bella's response i don't care come on
girl he's not even
trying to hide these red flags tell me
what you're thinking
edward became a vampire in 1918 so he's
a bit conservative when it comes to
romance
bella on the other hand is a modern day
woman and she wants edward
bad even when edward starts something he
usually pulls himself back before things
get out of control
but bella's always the one apologizing
so really
it's bella's fault for being so damn
delicious and edward's just being the
responsible one
right we'll be watching you whether
you're team edward
or jacob you gotta admit these guys have
some problems with boundaries
edward watching bella sleep seems kinda
romantic at first
he just wanted to be with her all the
time but now we realize that that's
called stalking
i like watching you sleep do you do that
a lot just the past couple of months
robert pattinson called out these
romantic moves when speaking with j-lo
for variety's actors on actors series
it's not that other people are telling
them they can't be together it's his own
body telling him that
if your body is telling you that not
being with someone is the only way to
save their life
you might want to listen since when a
vampire is like baseball
apparently vampires are passionate about
something other than blood
and it's baseball it's a random choice
for the cullen's favorite game and the
whole scene plays out like the most
dramatic match we've
ever seen there's also an awkward moment
where rosalie stares down bella
just for playing her very limited role
and she calls emmett my monkey man
between this and edward calling bella a
spider monkey
do the collins just have a thing for
primates
edward drinking bella's blood to get
james's venom out was a spur of the
moment kind of decision but can we just
talk about the faces these two pull in
this life-saving scene
edward's just about having the best
buffet of his life and bella's going
cross-eyed
it's a lot more awkward and painful than
most teen dramas
tell us vampire bites are supposed to be
i thought i wasn't gonna be able to stop
once bella pulls through after the whole
edward almost eats her thing
she gets a second chance to reconsider
all those red flags
instead she fights against the idea of
going back to jacksonville and literally
begs him to stay with her
that's like if you got stung by a
scorpion and the first thing you ask
after barely making it out alive is
can i keep it need to know i guess
it's hard enough raising a teenage girl
but it's a lot harder when she's dating
vampires
and werewolves the whole meet the
boyfriend scene was unnecessarily
awkward
edward is pretty old he should have
better social skills than this
and charlie and bella having the talk is
just heaps and heaps of cringe
okay don't don't have the talk not that
it would have helped anyway we're pretty
sure charlie doesn't have a handbook on
what to do when your daughter is dating
a vampire
it's just a thing right even without
edward bella
just can't seem to ditch the love
triangles when she ends up on a very
awkward three-way date with mike and
jacob
bella says no to wolf boy and he just
refuses to believe that she'll never be
into him
i'm not gonna give up serious question
has anyone ever tried to get out of the
friend zone harder than jacob black
i just couldn't live in the world
speaking of overreacting in the name of
love
edward about to shirtlessly sacrifice
himself in new moon was so melodramatic
we get that he doesn't know bella was
still alive
and let's be honest he's a bit of a
drama queen
but the pale shirtless walk the
sparkling his angsty facial expression
it's all a little much you feel
something else for me you just won't
admit it
also can we just talk about how jacob
kissing bella when she clearly tells him
no was pretty messed up
her attempt to show him she means
business by punching him in the face
just leaves her with a sore hand how
does that seem fair
it's also worth mentioning that kristen
stewart must have had a hard time taking
romance with taylor lautner seriously
since this is how they had to film all
those werewolf scenes
i am hotter than you so literally
who's hotter apparently it's jacob and
he uses that to his advantage
and shows off about his body heat to
edward before crawling into bed with
bella
to keep her warm robert pattinson admits
the tent scene gave him major
claustrophobia and he and taylor just
couldn't take
it seriously they forgot their lines and
kept cracking up about their strange
romantic rivalry
i'm really sorry about last night i
definitely won't make my list of top 10
favorite evenings
after the tent scene edward always went
to passive aggressively
stake his claim just can't leave well
enough alone he lets it slip that
bella's about to become mrs cullen
and what follows is jacob threatening to
get himself hurt in battle
and bella begging him to kiss her to try
and keep him from doing
anything stupid we're pretty sure this
counts as gaslighting
and jacob's kind of acting like a child
another one of your guests just arrived
it's gotta be at least a little weird
when your wife's favorite wedding
present is you inviting the man she
loves but just
not as much as you to the reception
jacob arriving at the wedding is awkward
enough but then he uses that time to
remind bella she's making the biggest
mistake of her life
and then they start talking about the
honeymoon now like tell me you're not
that stupid
seriously there are too many people
involved in edward and bella's
personal life this is totally necessary
according to breaking dawn part 1 a
severely destroyed bedroom must be a
sign of a good relationship
edward and bella's first time is pretty
intense with splintering bed frames and
feathers
everywhere it's framed as if it's
supposed to be romantic but it just
looks uncomfortable
if this is what it's like to get busy
with a vampire it's a good thing they're
rich enough to buy a thousand new bed
frames
that's what you're worried about the
whole scene where bella ends up bruised
on their honeymoon is also a bit
disturbing
first of all it's another reason for
edward to get super protective
and deny bella what she wants but it
also leads to a scene where bella tries
on a little black number
alice picked out for her in order to
entice edward bella is uncomfortable
we are uncomfortable but at least edward
had a good laugh
we can barely even say that bella's
whole pregnancy experience was
cringeworthy
it was just straight up terrifying it
was almost instantaneous
bella looked like a skeleton and labor
was an actual nightmare
plus working with newborns was pretty
awkward behind the scenes too
it was very traumatic and should be part
of a psa showing humans why they
shouldn't
fall in love and have babies with
centuries-old glittery vampires
it's a wolf thing the whole renesame
thing isn't just one cringy moment
it's an entire cringy plot line but it
did give us
this iconic scene of bella getting mad
at jacob for nicknaming her already
oddly named daughter after the walk this
monster
but then we have the fact that jacob
who's been crushing hard on bella was
really just destined to imprint with her
daughter
guess there is no werewolf left behind
when it comes to love but those family
dinners are going to be
really awkward yeah we're all going to
be together now
and speaking of nessie why just
why could they not have gotten multiple
children that looked similar enough to
play renesme at different ages
seeing her grow so rapidly was already
pretty jarring but the cgi used to keep
her face the same was
downright horrific mackenzie foy played
the older renesme
and to keep things consistent they
decided that superimposing her face
on all the younger renesmees would work
just fine what we got instead
was a face that only a mother could love
do you agree with our cringy moments any
other awkward moments you just couldn't
look away from
let us know in the comments don't forget
to hit that like button if you enjoyed
this video and subscribe to our channel
for more
thanks for watching